got a question here from a guy named
sterling rutherford there we go
so you got a question here about why it
seems so easy for
the modern young man to fall into
complacency and have an
average life yeah i am 18.
okay another youngin and yeah you think
that
that young men today are complacent
falling into an average life
yeah well it just seems you know
it's easy to go on the internet and on
youtube
and you know listen to guys like you
talk about
success and stuff but when you go out
into the
when i go out into the real world you
know and i see it just
it seems so common it seems so easy
for guys to work you know for example a
retail job for
30 years you know and it just it seems
discouraging
to me you know i mean how
i don't want to be like pessimistic but
how do you
realistically no i think i know what
you're saying i mean like i worked a
retail job
um how old was i maybe 18 or 19. maybe
for about two or three years i worked
this retail job at a stereo store
vcrs tvs like stereos you know i used to
do installs like
you know surround sound stuff and
people's homes it paid
[ __ ] yeah like it look the pay was
pretty crap
do you have do you have youtube running
somewhere else i'm getting feedback
somewhere
i don't know if you got another screen
if you can mute it um
but you don't want to stay in that
position for too long like
i would tell every guy here i'm just
going to mute you for a sec while i'm
talking so i don't get that feedback but
i would tell every guy to work a [ __ ]
job at least once in your life
i've done a few i've i've planted uh
sorry i've
pruned christmas trees in the summer
heat and that
and in that job you have to get up at
4am to do it at the crack of dawn
in the summer because you can't prune it
at like high heat in the summertime so
when you're 16
and you're up at 4 00 am to prune
[ __ ] christmas trees
at minimum wage that's about the
shittiest job that you can do
and i got fired from that job because
the guy didn't like the way that i
shaped the tree
right it's like forgive me buddy you're
paying me peanuts i'm driving all the
way out here at four o'clock in the
morning to shave down your trees
and it's not straight enough for you
right so
every guy should work a crap job at some
point to realize
that working those crap jobs
should be part of the launch pad to get
you to you know start thinking about
chasing excellence
um i don't know if you ever heard kevin
o'leary's story but
he talked about this um ice cream shop
that he worked at
and how the owner of the shop was like a
witch and made him scrape gum off the
floor
you know sort of thing like that kind of
thing so
if that's what you're okay with and if
that's the complacency that you know
you want to stay in you got nobody to
blame but yourself but if you look at
your job
you know when you go to it and you're
like dreading even going to the job
then you have to realize it's actually a
good thing because
that's your like that's you that's your
intuition telling you hey buddy like you
can do better than this like let's
you know let's step it up here again men
have the burden of performance in
society all women have to do is show up
and look pretty
okay they like the hardest thing that
women have to do today
is not get fat and be pleasant not be
disagreeable
not become one of these boss [ __ ] and
all that kind of stuff but
be pleasant be agreeable enter a man's
frame sort of thing
and compliment his life not be the focus
of it guys have to
like do something they have to learn
competency skills they have to learn the
ability to make bank right you know to
make it rain
they also have to know how to preside
they also have to know to know how to
protect and defend themselves and
anyone around them in their inner circle
if they have a family if they have
friends whatever
like these are important skills that
guys need to learn but nobody's telling
guys these things anymore
everybody's telling guys i don't worry
about it you know does somebody offend
you
there's a safe space over here for you
to sit in blah blah blah
and that's a function of society bubble
wrapping children
and parents helicopter parenting
children and
an epidemic of single-parent households
which is mostly single mother households
raising boys without fathers there's a
lack of masculinity in the world
i cover a lot of this in my book too
right so
why are men you know like this today
there's a lot of reasons why but men
don't have to be like that and the good
news is
you can stand out like a shining star
from a
sea of of turkeys right you want to soar
like an eagle
it's it's a lot easier to do today when
most guys are just happy
walking the ground being a turkey
complaining about their life
sulking it's not fair
oh boo freaking who okay
life is hard [ __ ] deal with it
make yourself better you know stand up
and go and do the work
that's that's what most guys fail at and
if you can take ownership for that and
you can go and do that
you'll be just fine i mean you're 18
right yeah
yeah you'll be just fine man you
understanding this now
and recognizing that there's work to be
done and start executing on that work
and getting better month after month
year after year
don't beat yourself up too much at 18.
okay if you're 38
i would say okay we need to have a
conversation i've often said to guys
look
if you're if you're 18 and you're an
alpha chad like
you're a good looking guy but you have a
plan
that's all you need right now okay if
you're 38 or 48
and you're maybe a good looking guy
still but all you have is a plan
that ain't good enough at that age okay
so
if you have a plan start executing on it
if you don't have a plan figure out what
that plan is
yeah right with that all right
i mean i guess it's just the
i don't it just it seems so so sad to me
it's just it's the thing
that i deal with on an everyday basis
you know like i work at fedex i work at
the home depot
you know it's like every time the
higher-ups are always like
you know you want to be here for 30
years man you want to be here for 20
40 years man and it's just like i
i don't know it's just like it depresses
me you know because i i want to make
sure that i don't have a false sense of
entitlement you know like i want to go
and start a business i want to go and do
this
do that right i don't want to work a
[ __ ] retail job
until the end of time man you know i
just
you know i just want to make sure that
i'm being realistic about it
yeah cool so because everyone is stuck
in that
i don't get don't get mad at yourself
so get mad at yourself and hold yourself
accountable
because people don't hold others
today anymore women are no longer
accountable they can do whatever the
[ __ ] they want
you know they can make up of me too
without any proof whatsoever and ruin a
guy's life like there's no
accountability
same thing with men right i'll just
whatever i'll work that retail job for
20 years i'll i'll sit at home
i'll i'll i'll go and search the
internet for here i got to meet you
again
i'm going to go and search the internet
for crap that's going to
you know support my narrative of of why
i should be sulking here about the cards
i've been dealt
stop being a [ __ ] is really what it
boils down to
just double down and do the [ __ ] work
right and if you can start with that
men's hat like that's all that david
goggins is all about right like he's
basically like don't be a [ __ ] and do
the work sort of thing right
you see him yelling at people
dan pena another guy start
start like i'll leave you with this
thought you know before we wrap up
you're going to become the average of
the people that you spend the most time
with so if you're hanging out with guys
that have been in the retail space for
30 or 40 years
telling you that this is all that you're
ever going to amount to
you're the smartest guy in the room get
the [ __ ] out of that room
put yourself in a room where you're not
the smartest guy in the room and
surround yourself with greater people
and if you can't find a room to surround
yourself with greater people
you can watch youtube videos from guys
that have chased greatness you can read
books and study excellence
uh read biographies of successful
entrepreneurs
the everything store is a book about
amazon and jeff bezos
if you want to learn about
entrepreneurship and the kind of [ __ ]
that
men chasing excellence need to do to put
a dent in the universe
read stuff about that and get inspired i
didn't have anybody inspire me my
my dad was a basic you know corporate
droid
you know he never had a successful
business but i took a look around at
everybody i'm like
[ __ ] this you know i grew up in a
household where
food was rationed i was only able to
have like one yogurt a day because if i
ate more than that then that was no good
i'd get yelled at
and we were told as kids me and my
brothers how to take a [ __ ] and how many
times you had to fold the toilet paper
to get the most out of it
so that you didn't use too much toilet
paper like this is the kind of house
that i grew up on
and i'm like [ __ ] this right so
get mad and then just go out and start
doing the work
on it make sense
hang on i need you there you good all
right yes sir
yes sir thank you see you man
you